bonjour à tous alors première petite
question est il imaginable qu'un pilote
de formule 1 ne connaissent pas le
fonctionnement de sa voiture évidemment
non est il imaginable qu'un joueur de
football ne connaissent pas la règle du
jeu auquel ils jouent évidemment non est
il imaginable que tous les profs et les
élèves ne connaissent pas le mode de
fonctionnement d'un outil qu'ils
utilisent en permanence et de manière
intensive
évidemment non et bien pourtant c'est ce
qui arrive actuellement dans le domaine
de l'éducation en france car ce fameux
outil mystérieux dont je vous parle et
dont le mode de fonctionnement est
méconnu des principaux intéressés
et bien c'est notre ami le cerveau alors
de mon côté je suis prof de maths dans
un lycée vous inquiétez pas thales
pythagore
on dit qu'il ne serait pas là
aujourd'hui vous pouvez vous détendre il
ya cinq ans j'enseignais dans une
première dit de consolidation où nous
avions regrouper les élèves qui étaient
passés de secondes en première
scientifique de manière un petit peu
juste
et pour les aider à avoir leur bac avec
plus de facilité nous avions recruté une
équipe de super prof c'était les profs
les plus novateurs du lycée les plus
dans le pédagogique les plus en
relationnel les plus aimées des élèves
en voici une photo à peine retouchée
alors cependant au bout de six mois il a
fallu faire un premier bilan et ce
premier bilan et bien été un peu
décevant puisque 50% des élèves stagné
au niveau où on les avait recruté en
face à ce semi échec et à cette
constatation
je cherchais une explication et j'ai
alors un jour posé la question aux
élèves aux fêtes
pensez vous que l'intelligence est une
donnée fixé à la naissance ou qu elle
s'acquiert au fil du temps et de la vie
réponse 50% des élèves de la classe
pensait que l'intelligence était une
donnée fixé à la naissance qu'on essaie
intelligent ou limitées et pire encore
ou circonstance aggravante si vous
voulez que ça perdure et tout
long de notre vie alors que l'on sait
désormais que ceci est un non sens
scientifique total car grâce aux
dernières avancées en neurosciences nous
avons la preuve sans cesse renouvelé
caen fait plus le cerveau et stimuler et
de manière différente plus ils se
développent et ça ne vous étonnera pas
si je vous dis que les fameuses élèves
qui pensaient que l'intelligence était
une donnée fixé à la naissance une bonne
fois pour toutes étaient les mêmes que
ceux qui plafonné j'ai alors compris
qu'il se brider eux mêmes et qu'il en
était ainsi partout en france
c'est grâce à cette révélation que j'ai
créé le projet ne reçu que je mène pas
réellement à mon travail de prof et dont
l'ambition est de dévoiler un petit peu
partout en france aux profs et aux
élèves les liens qui lient à entre le
fonctionnement du cerveau et des astuces
des méthodes d'apprentissage
alors aujourd'hui pendant quelques
minutes je voudrais partager avec vous
trois connaissances fondamentales de
neurosciences qui vont à l'encontre de
trois fausses croyances communes que
nous avons pour la plupart ou en tout
cas pour la plupart d'entre nous nous
avons eu alors là aussi ne vous
inquiétez pas il n'y a pas de bagage
scientifique nécessaire pour comprendre
ce que je vais dire et il n'y a même pas
d'humiliation publique prévue la charte
de tmx est très stricte
à ce niveau là hélas j'ai dû me plier je
vous donne donc d'abord les titres et
après je rentrerai dans l'utah
la première de ces connaissances c'est
que le cerveau et face il ne fait pas
qu'enregistrer puis nous verrons la
deuxième connaissance à savoir que le
cerveau n'est pas multitâche que l'on
soit jeune conçoit ag conçoit un homme
que l'on soit une femme et enfin
troisième et dernière connaissance que
nous verrons c'est que le cerveau est un
véritable transformiste et ils se re
configure sans cesse alors comment sont
justement par la première longtemps nous
avons cru que le cerveau puisque c'était
une machine à apprendre
c'était forcément une machine qui ne
faisait qu enregistrez vous pouvez
passer que par pathologie et que de
surcroît s'il en avait compris quelque
chose
alors forcément on l'avait mémorisées et
bien sûr vous montrer une petite vidéo
qui va vous prouver le contraire
cette vidéo c'est tout simplement une
petite publicité que vous avez peut-être
vu il ya trois ou quatre ans qui passait
sur les télévisions françaises
c'est pour un gel douche dont j'ai juste
ôtez le nom à la fin de la publicité
félicitations si vous avez le gel douche
en question dans votre salle de bain je
m'incline mais cela ne vous servira à
rien pour la petite expérience qui va
suivre
car effectivement il s'agit d'une petite
expérience
et comme je ne peux pas vous en dire
plus eh bien je vais vous passez la
vidéo et on en parle juste après ces
produits alors à stéphanie léa et amis
me
ok on y va
ah ah alors je vous pose naïvement la
question comment s'appelle cette jeune
femme alors nous avons un courant
stéphanie nous avons un courant sahara
nous avons un courant léa et nous avons
un courant silencieux les sans opinions
de tadjiks alsace eh bien figurez-vous
que il n'y a pas à s'inquiéter
je parle au sans opinion puisque après
tout le personnage est exactement dans
la même situation
personnage clé joué par la caméra alors
on peut légitimement se demander mais
enfin comment ça se fait que je n'ai pas
mémoriser les choses alors qu'un prénom
c'est pas difficile à comprendre
donc je l' ai compris et pourtant ce
n'est pas mémoriser et bien parce qu'il
faut savoir que grâce aux avancées en
neurosciences on a découvert avec
certitude que le cerveau a fait
effectivement une tendance à enregistrer
facilement quand il se trouvait que les
informations qu'il recevait était utile
pour le futur proche mais il a il avait
également tendance à effacer
très rapidement des informations qu'il
pensait inutile pour le futur proche
pour vous donner une analogie ce serait
celle d'un physionomiste de boîte de
nuit
je suis désolé je suis allé si j'aurais
évoque quelques souvenirs difficiles
pour vous un physionomiste de boîte de
nuit qui laisse passer votre ami
charmant et qui vous laissent par contre
vous sur le trottoir méditer sur vos
baskets pourtant si confortable et au
vert fluo si tendance années 80 alors
c'est ce qui est arrivé au personnage
principal de la vidéo en fait il ne
savait pas que mémorisées illettré nom
de ces quatre jeunes filles allaient
être utile dans un futur si proche
puisque l'un la jeune femme a déjà
commencé une approche de séduction et là
le personnage hommes-femmes est joué par
la caméra va le payer très cher
je ne peux pas avoir mémorisé les choses
alors que si son ami lui avait dit
écoute demain sur le campus de
l'université je vous présenterai quatre
de mes copines
il y en a une par mi elle qui est folle
dingue de toi
folle amoureuse elle veut sortir avec
toi oui je sais tu ne lui a jamais parlé
mais que veux tu sais ton charisme et
bien à ce moment là je vous assure que
le lendemain vous mémoriser les quatre
prennent car vous savez qu'il ya une
utilité pour le futur proche à le faire
alors conclusion quand vous voudrez que
vos interlocuteurs mémorise les
informations que vous leur donnez ce
soit vos parents vos élèves
vos enfants vos collègues et bien
n'hésitez pas dans un premier temps à
eur annoncé la couleur
c'est à dire d'abord à donner l'objectif
puis à dire eh bien pour atteindre cet
objectif il va falloir que tu mémorise
les informations que je vais te donner
maintenant
ainsi vous leur envoyez vous envoyer à
leur cerveau un message d'utilité pour
le futur proche et évidemment pour clore
cette première des trois partis je ne
vais pas vous laisser sans une deuxième
projection de la petite publicité pour
réjouir ceux qui ont trouvé tout de
suite pour récupérer quelques partisans
de la bonne réponse et pour désespérer
mais ne vous inquiétez pas c'est tout à
fait normal
ceux qui resteront toujours sans opinion
allons-y à la réalité sarah stéphanie
léa et amis
ok on y va
alors que pensez vous oui via bravo
c'est bien elle
c'est notre amie stéphanie alors passons
à la deuxième connaissances
fondamentales en neurosciences le
cerveau n'est pas multitâche vous dire
comment on commence on n'est pas mieux
du tage me suis moi je suis multi tâches
en fait nous sommes très nombreux à nous
qualifier de multitâche parce que nous
sommes sur sollicité dans notre
quotidien
nous parlons à nos enfants pendant que
nous envoyons des mails nous regardons
la télé tout en envoyant ou en lisant
des textos c'est tout juste si on se
sentait pas capable de calmer un
éléphant en furie dans notre salle de
bain pendant qu'on les a on lance une
lessive de linge sale
tout en prenant un rendez-vous au
téléphone chez l'ostéopathe jeudi quand
même les sciences est une chose mais
enfin moi je sais que je suis multi
tâches alors il faut savoir qu'en fait
pour le scientifique être multitâche
ce n'est pas exactement pareil que pour
l'homme où la femme de la rue être
multitâche pour le scientifique c'est
vraiment est ce que le cerveau est
capable de faire deux choses
concurrentiel exactement en même temps
et pas globalement dans 5 minutes faire
plein de choses
en parallèle est bien là la réponse est
non ce n'est pas possible
le cerveau ne peut pas le faire sauf
dans un cas quand l'une des deux tâches
et d'automatiser exemple classique vous
rentrez pour la millième fois chez vous
à bord de votre voiture est bien là vous
avez forcément une connaissance de votre
chemin qui a été automatisé
vous pouvez avoir n'importe quel
passager qui lui tient n'importe quelle
conversation même ennuyeuse vous pouvez
le suivre tout en roulant
par contre transférer vous avec la même
voiture
le même passagers mais cette fois ci
dans une grande ville que vous ne
connaissez absolument pas où vous devez
chercher votre chemin sans gps prenons
rome pour que ce soit plus drôle côté
circulation et même pourquoi pas un rond
point romain
pour que l'on soit sûr que vous ne
perdiez pas de vue la chose est bien à
ce moment là quand votre passager va
vous interroger sur ce que vous pensez
des caractéristiques techniques de sa
nouvelle tondeuse à gazon qu'il vient
d'acheter
vous aurez certainement plutôt tendance
à lui dire attends attends attends tu es
toi tu et à toi je crois que j'ai raté
la sortie
et puis pourquoi ils mettent pas de
panneau et puis pourquoi ils mettent pas
de clignotant mais il met le bras d'or
pour dire qu'ils vont tourner bref pas
de multitâche à rome mais pas de
multitâche non plus d'ailleurs
alors vous me direz mais alors si le
cerveau ne fonctionne pas en multitâches
comment fonctionne-t-il eh bien ce sont
les images suivantes
il suit d'arte et qui vont nous
l'expliqué les recherches le confirme il
n'y a pas de différences entre hommes et
femmes dont le travail multi tâches en
réalité le cerveau ne peut se concentrer
pleinement que sur une seule chose à la
fois le multitâche impliquant au moins
deux activités simultanées
il faut déplacer l'attention
alternativement de l'une à l'autre
et oui c'est cela la vérité scientifique
c'est que le twr le cerveau travaille en
alternance des tâches alors il y à un
conseil de la sécurité routière que l'on
comprend encore mieux désormais c'est à
dire ne pensez pas que vous ne prenez
aucun risque
quand vous envoyer un texto pendant que
vous conduisez comme le dit si joliment
la chercheure elena pas ce qui les lie
au sujet justement de cette situation
quand vous tentez ce coup là en fait
votre cerveau pendant quelques dixièmes
de seconde il conduit pendant quelques
dixièmes de seconde
il écrit je conduis j'écris je conduis
j'écris j'ai vite le lapin j'écrase le
lapin
conclusion à chaque fois que vous en
aurez la possibilité chez vous dans
votre milieu professionnel
n'hésitez pas à faire du mono tâche de
l' étape par étape
c'est ce que préfère votre cerveau c'est
ce pour quoi il est fait et il sera très
efficace et si dans votre environnement
familial vous étiez jusqu'à présent tout
content de dire mais moi au moins je
suis multi tâche par rapport à toi eh
bien vous pourrez tous eu cours or je ne
connais personne dans la salle
eh bien vous pourrez toujours dire oui
mais moi je suis plus performant que toi
dans l'alternance des tâches ce sera
aussi jouissif mais cette fois ci en
plus la science sera de votre côté
enfin dernière des connaissances
fondamentales en neurosciences le
cerveau est un véritable transformiste
là aussi on pensait que le cerveau une
fois arrivé à son âge adulte qui est de
25 ans scientifiquement et bien il ne
changeait plus un peu comme notre taille
à partir de l'âge adulte ne change plus
mais dans ce cas là comment expliquer
que la force de jouer du piano en joue
de plus en plus facilement et cannes
inverse quand on s'arrête pendant
quelques années de jouer du piano et
bien quand on veut s'y remettre c'est
pas tout à fait aussi facile que quand
on avait arrêté
si les neurones qui codent l'action je
joue du piano était figée dans le temps
nous n'aurions aucune difficulté à
reprendre au stade où on avait arrêté
c'est donc bien qu'il se passe quelque
chose et bien ce quelque chose c'est ce
qu'on appelle la plasticité cérébrale
c'est à dire qu'à chaque instant de
notre journée chaque instant de notre
vie notre cerveau reconfigurer son
architecture interne aussi fou que cela
puisse paraître
vous n'avez pas le même cerveau cet
après midi que vous l'aviez ce matin et
vous n'aurez pas le même ce soir que
celui que vous avez cet après midi alors
rassurez vous quand vous rentrerez chez
vous ce soir vos proches vos enfants
votre conjoint vous reconnaîtront
très facilement enfin d'après ce qu'on
m'a dit la plupart du temps voyons
quelques images montrant de neurones qui
se connectent toujours en direct d'arte
et notre cerveau et plastiques et
adaptable nous réagissons en permanence
à notre environnement toute perception
toute action toute adaptation à un
impact sur l'organisation de notre
cerveau
en permanence des cellules nerveuses
sont activés ou désactivés
les réseaux se font et se défont des
milliards de neurones collaborent
au bout
mon monde
on
c'est impressionnant n'est-ce pas alors
nous pouvons garder en tête deux images
analogie de la plasticité cérébrale
d'abord un chemin de randonnée plus il
est fréquentée par les randonneurs plus
il se creuse et plus il devient stable
malgré les pluies il ne s'effacera pas
c'est l'équivalent de jeu joue du piano
de plus en plus et j'en joue donc de
mieux en mieux par contre si vous
n'empruntez qu'une seule fois ce chemin
à peine il est construit que il peut
s'effacer là pour le cerveau c'est
l'équivalent de neurones qui se
déconnectent puis on leur liaison qui
disparaît et puis la dernière petite
analogie c'est la fantastique
possibilités du cerveau de se connecter
d'avoir ces neurones qui se connecte
avec d'autres un peu comme l'expansion
du réseau autoroutier français multiplie
les possibilités d'aller vers une ville
donnée paris est bien pour l'information
c'est pareil sauf que pour le cerveau
c'était une échelle vertigineuse nous
avons 100 milliards de neurones dans
notre cerveau qui peuvent se connecter
chacun à dix villes autres alors grâce à
la plasticité cérébrale et bien adieu au
mythe du défaitisme du fatalisme du je
suis nul en anglais comme mes parents du
oui bien sûr je peux progresser mais
enfin si c'est dans trois ans moi
j'aurais jamais le temps et le courage
d'attendre
etc etc tout ceci est faux puisque la
plasticité cérébrale elle et de chaque
instant alors conclusion lorsque dans
votre vie vous serez amené à douter de
vous même ou si un jour il y a quelqu'un
qui vous fait douter de vous même
n'hésitez pas à vous rappeler de la
plasticité cérébrale et à vous dire et
ben tant pis j'y vais quand même parce
que je sais que mon cerveau va me suivre
et effectivement il va vous suivre et
vous serez plus heureux
merci à vous et bonne soirée